obviously smile I'm just gonna smile and
laugh what he says hi I'm a penis I was
not ready I will be the vagina i'm ryan
right i'm ryan the vagina shoes yes the
vagina shoes shoes for your vagina
Charlie Kaufman has a stop-motion
animation movie out animal Lisa and I
love Charlie Kaufman films let's see
this strong sexual graphic nudity love
claymation nudity stop-motion
what is it to be human what is it take
what is it to be alive each person you
speak to has had a day its claymation
some of the days of being good some bad
all very films all of them speak to has
had a childhood each has a body each
body has inks
look for what is special about each
individual focus on that
[ __ ] to make
remember that is someone out there for
everyone
whoa Wow really an extraordinary why I
don't know yet it's just obvious to me
that you are
time is limited we forget that
sorry vinaigrette your hand okay
it's a reflux I don't like the fly I
said it's okay and let go now them eat
neato burrito right hand please
feel that really hard
nipple chills well that's um look
beautiful yeah it really did it looks
like a beautiful Ike when it's a it's
coming out this is this this is Oscar
season stuff yeah I hope you getting
into it because this comments out
December 30th it gets a wide wider
release on the in January yeah that's
really pretty and I'm excited to see the
storyline because those ones are the
ones you can really dive into
emotionally I would totally watch this
just based off that one trailer like I
don't need to see another trailer no
that looks so fantastic that stop-motion
effects look great
is it half claymation it works like it
it does know fantastic mr. Fox yeah see
Anderson Bros did that mm-hmm you hear
about it like almost tore their
relationship apart because it was so
difficult to film I hear these are like
then they take years to put together the
result from these things for me I know
some people like don't really relate to
it that well but for me I don't know
there's something about it that's just
so like I know it brings almost like a
Toy Story feel like it's all emotionally
involved and then it's fun and looks
cool and your imagination goes a little
while the one thing about this trailer
that I feel can be misleading is it
looks like families can watch it but I
saw the rating before it and I'm like
yeah I didn't get a sense of any strong
sexual content and graphic nudity that
would not say this as a family movie the
fact that it's done so beautifully and
there's such a visual style to it like I
feel like when I watched the movie the
stop-motion effect is gonna even make
more sense for why they specifically
chose to do that for this yeah and it
also looked like it took place over a
long period of time they got it looks
like it does which those are always
great that you don't have to age an
actor because I think a lot of times
that
take you out of a movie if you like this
makeup stuff gets in the way which it's
gotten very good these days but I like
that it would be a progression where you
know it's kind of a flawless progression
of age you know in some ways this seems
like an adult version of inside out to
me
super raunchy very subjects that yeah
like very adult subjects yeah that's
what the vibe I'm sorry there are a lot
of hotel rooms in this is probably a lot
of sleeping around there's gonna be like
stop-motion sex scenes and nudity it's
gonna be hot a whole new wave of porn is
coming our way people yeah it's gonna
open the door I don't think that's new
man stop-motion pornography oh maybe I
was thinking just anime stuff oh yes can
you imagine Oh frustrating yeah this
poor not took a year and a half my
brother apart I don't know I mean
there's not much to really say other
than the tone and visual imagery is
great it looks like what they're
exploring the adult themes seem awesome
I'm interested to see a raw film like a
Ross storytelling through stop-motion
yeah I love the emotional journey that
like the movies before were Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind and what
would that being John Malkovich oh the
emotional journeys that those characters
take are amazing an eternal sunshine is
one of my all-time favorite film Being
John Malkovich is one of my all-time
favorites and adaptation is somewhere up
there to me now we can both like that
equal amounts yeah cool cool cool anyway
guys buds listen dudes and dudettes if
you're new to the channel click this
button above my head cuz apparently I've
been instructed to to guide people on
where to click it you guys couldn't
figure that out apparently not people
are or people have figured out and they
just don't want click that but let's say
that they didn't know where it was yeah
I'll go with that it's a called denial P
and Orion shoes star of the gallows huh
it's my impression of you in the couch
yeah as far as my Ryan shoes impression
guys I'm a dick guys guys where are you
Reese
guys you have to watch the move you guys
you have to watch it baby he's on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter as well
we got a shout out at us
Michael Young hey Ryan just want to say
that I love your videos and your sense
of humor
that's not fight dude those are like
serious conditions that can happen in
the brain you can develop it like in
your this is what you like about him
well it's oh you're a saint tumor
serious sense of tumour serious sense of
tumor means I'm funny humor is just a
can make fun of humors Michael Young you
terrible-tasting terrible tasting comedy
I blame you for my jokes I would love it
if you could give me a shout-out I have
a drum cover channel nice and a gaming
channel I'm sure those cross-promote
each other perfectly and I'm trying to
help trying to get back into making more
videos it would be a big help
Thanks PS Briana's teeth are very nice
and I think I'm in love okay come on
these pearly woods yeah scrubbing keep
up the drum covers and keep up the
gaming it's about persistence and tag
you can combine the two man drum covers
of gaming she do like games like the
Super Mario Brothers but that's
executive that would be so cool you're
welcome
we just practically built your channel
for you and unless you don't do two
channels now yeah this way easy and now
be unique most of the subscribers look
like serial killers like yes is that a
bunny yes this is total serious serial
killer oh come on
you cannot tell me this guy doesn't look
like a serial killer bunny Carlos this
is the largest bunny I've ever seen
Carlos can you come here for one second
come here careless oh this is the last
guy I don't want to be in first you
remember one second tell me if this guy
looks like a serial killer to you you
know what yeah you got to get your face
in here's our sound guy
you know this is much cozier yeah
careless you know dude this is Ryan Ryan
now let's all bond over the serial
killer nature of this guy's case
everybody huh
pony the bottom one he's probably gonna
kill that bunny